hey youtubers is Charlie so exciting
news we may have a release date for wins
a winner or at least a really solid idea
for the time of year it's going to be
dropping next year so here we go
so the real big news this past week if
you guys didn't see it is that winds of
winner received sort of like an
international serial number books get
like a certain serial number as they're
registered by publishers so martin's
publisher registered winds of winter but
then a bunch of people pointed out that
book publishers do that all the time and
sometimes they'll change it doesn't
necessarily indicate that a release is
coming up but it made it seem like the
release date was going to be next spring
so everyone was going crazy then this
shows up on the French amazon site where
like Amazon will sometimes have
pre-orders available and it'll tell you
the release date that's currently
scheduled so this says 9th of March 2017
so naturally everyone's freaking out oh
my god it's coming but the thing is is
when I went to the United States Amazon
site the place of our I order books from
I couldn't find this so a couple things
going on you know one they probably have
a pretty good idea of when they're gonna
release wins a winner but the date could
change just in the way that video game
release dates can get pushed like in
related genre fare if you're a big Final
Fantasy franchise fan Sony's releasing
the new installment of that this year
but it got pushed into November
originally it was gonna be released a
little bit earlier in the year so
naturally like when they announced the
earlier release date i pre-ordered it
but then Amazon came back to me like a
little while later and was like hey the
release dates been pushed this is when
it's coming out now
so just because a release date is on
Amazon does it mean that that will
absolutely be the release date it could
always get pushed a little bit later in
the year but I still think there's a
really solid chance that they will
release the book before season 7 drops
because season 7 isn't coming until the
middle of June so Martin almost has like
the whole first part of the year to
finish the book the thing you have to
remember though is that it takes time to
bind the book like once he submits the
final version to his publisher they have
to look over it again then they actually
have to make the physical book and ship
it all over the world that takes a
little while so even if he finishes the
book like right before season 7 it's
probably gonna take a couple weeks after
that before you can buy a physical copy
but I'm still really optimistic that it
will drop before season
and starts and for those of you that are
wondering there are a couple big things
that have already changed between the
book plot in the TV show plot there are
two really big characters that are still
alive in the book so I'll say spoiler
warning one more time Stannis is still
alive he's getting ready for like the
big ramsay battle that you saw in
episode 9 during season 6 Theon has
already been reunited with his sister
she's a captive of Stannis they've
already had the Kingsmoot and she's lost
you kind of saw that play out on the TV
show but instead of Sansa it's actually
fake Arya Jane Poole sonses old friend
from King's Landing
that's wid Theon so Sansa at this point
is still in the Vale hiding out with
Littlefinger Arya has not come back to
Westeros yet and Jon Snow has just been
stepped so for a lot of characters in
the books the TV show has already passed
their book plot but some of them are
still behind in another big character
that's still alive kind of a fan
favorite who's one of my favorites but
Barristan Selmy is still alive in the
books he actually has some POV chapters
during winds of winter so whereas like
the earlier seasons of Game of Thrones
it was kind of fun to pick out like the
little changes from the books to the
show now it's gonna be fun to pick out
the little similarities because they've
diverged so much every time someone asks
Martin at a public appearance is like
you know my books totally different from
the TV show enjoy the TV show enjoy the
books all the same but they're totally
different and as far as I know like he
probably gives them like a few minor
tweaks on the new season but he's not
writing any scripts so largely like he
isn't doing as much work with the TV
show as he has done in past seasons but
a really interesting thing I know a lot
of you are like hey you know I really
want like a version of the TV show
that's more like the books so here's
something like if you don't know who max
Brooks is he's Mel Brooks his son he
wrote World War Z he writes a lot of
really cool post apocalyptic genre
stories so what he did is is because
they made that awful Brad Pitt World War
Z movie based on his book like they
bought his script then completely
changed his story turned it into a
really terrible movie and separately
what he did is when it came time to do
the audiobook for one of his books is he
got all the actors that he really
respected and he did like a radio drama
the way Neil Gaiman has done for some of
his books so I don't know
actly what Martin's sold in terms of the
Breitling he sold the TV rights of Game
of Thrones the main novels Song of Ice
and Fire
to HBO I don't know if he could do a
radio drama of Game of Thrones but they
could totally do a version of that in
the future that is exactly the books
word-for-word
so if you ever wanted a version of Game
of Thrones that was exactly like the
books I feel like radio drama is the way
to do that but I'm not expecting that to
happen anytime soon they're kind of
expensive if the actors don't do it for
relatively low money and I don't know if
they would get the TV actors to do it
they would probably be happy to do it
but I'm sure like once Game of Thrones
is over they're gonna want to go and do
other things for a little while so just
put like a pin in that you can ask
George are Martin to the next time you
see him at a convention will you ever do
a radio drama version of A Song of Ice
and Fire and if you are a big fan of
audiobooks they are really good about
releasing audiobook versions of all the
main novel I'm not a super huge fan of
Roy dotrice
I mean he does a pretty good job but
still right now my all-time favorite
audio but your straight-up audiobook
narrator is Jim Dale from the Harry
Potter series but let me know in the
comments would you ever want them to do
a radio drama of A Song of Ice and Fire
keep in mind that it would probably be a
little bit longer than the current
duration of the audiobooks which you
know many many hours but I feel like
that's what people want that like they
want more Game of Thrones they want the
books so radio drama just feels like a
no-brainer once they figure out the
economics of it but just to jump back to
the TV show really what's happening
right now is that they're gearing up to
start filming the main actors have now
slowly started to show up to set so
we'll probably start seeing like a
little bit more from what's going on
behind the scenes like I'm actually
filming scenes with Tyrion Jon Snow
Sansa all the different characters
Daenerys so get hype and congratulations
to this week's giveaway winner striker
163 you win a $20 Amazon gift card be
sure to private message me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact details and for those that are
wondering it should go without saying
but once we do get an official release
date for winds of winter I will do
giveaways for copies of the book I've
done that with previous game of Thrones
book releases so what's gonna happen
later tonight is there's some new Ghost
Rider footage from agents of shield
there's some new thor ragnarok they'll
be like some new Marvel DC so that
should post a little bit later tonight
while you guys wait for that to post you
click here for my season 7 cast video
and you can click here to learn all
about the flash movie and how the
Justice League is changing a little bit
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight
you